Every biological process can be traced
back to genes, and in many cases,
specific diseases can be linked to
mistakes in genes. Understanding the
exact role a gene plays in biology or
disease is challenging, however,
because multicellular organisms like
humans are complex. Just over 30 years
ago, a group of scientists made a
pivotal discovery that led to the
development of an important tool that
changed the way scientists could study
the role of a single gene and its
impact on an entire biological system:
the knockout mouse. You can think of a
knockout mouse like baking a cake with
an ingredient removed. Removing even
one ingredient can lead to a cake that
doesn't rise properly or isn't sweet
enough. Similarly, taking away a single
gene in an organism can reveal what key
ingredient that gene provides to making
a fully functional organism. While the
theory is simple, the process of making
a knockout mouse is complex and took
decades to develop. To make a knockout
mouse, researchers first isolate
embryonic stem cells (ES cells) from an
early mouse embryo, one of the earliest
developmental stages of any organism.
Most ES cells are a type of cell that
still have the potential to develop
into any cell or tissue in the body.
So, if a gene is removed from them then
all subsequent cells and tissues will
also be devoid of the gene. One of the
most common ways scientists can remove
a gene from ES cells is using a method
called homologous recombination. In
this process, a piece of DNA containing
identical genetic sequences to the
region surrounding the gene of interest
is used to swap out genetic material in
the ES cell by either rendering the
gene dysfunctional with the addition of
a mutation or replacing it with some
DNA that interferes with the gene.
After the gene is removed, the ES cells
are inserted into a mouse embryo and
implanted into the uterus of a female
mouse. The resulting baby mice will
have some tissues where the desired
gene is removed, those originating from
the ES cell, and others where it is
not, those originating from the embryo
itself. These mice are known as
chimeric mice, named after an ancient
greek beast, the chimera, consisting of
body parts from several different
animals. To generate mice where the
target gene is gone in all cells, the
partial knockout mouse is bred with a
normal mouse. The resulting mouse
litter will have some mice where one
copy of the target gene is removed,
also called heterozygotes. These
heterozygotes are further bred together
over several generations to produce a
line of mice where the desired gene is
completely removed, also known as
homozygous knockouts. This discovery of
how to make a knockout mouse was so
critical that the three scientists
involved won the Nobel Prize in
Physiology or Medicine in 1997. Since
then, knockout mice have been critical
contributors to numerous scientific
advances. Given humans and mice are
identical in 85% of genes that make
proteins, studying a gene's role in a
mouse can provide critical insights to
human biology and disease. One of the
first examples was the creation of a
mouse model for cystic fibrosis, a
disease caused by a mutation in the
CFTR gene. Knocking out this one gene
in mice recapitulated many of the
cystic fibrosis symptoms observed in
humans, allowing scientists to
understand the complexities of this
disease, ultimately helping us treat
the same condition in humans. Since
then, mouse models have advanced
research for numerous diseases
including arthritis, various cancers
and Parkinson's disease. In recent
years, knockout mouse technology has
evolved considerably, most recently
with the advent of CRISPR-Cas9.
CRISPR-Cas9 is based on a naturally
occurring immune system in bacteria to
target and change specific genetic
locations.
This method provides several benefits.
One, it can edit genes within an embryo
itself, which can bypass the need for
ES cells. This also allows editing in
animal models other than mice, as ES
cells are not available for most
animals. Two, it is extremely precise
and can edit multiple genetic locations
simultaneously. And three, it can
create a knockout mouse in about six
months, compared to the nearly two
years more traditional methods require.
As with any scientific method, knockout
mice also have certain drawbacks. Some
genes, for example, are so essential
that removing them leads to the death
of the embryo or a mouse that cannot
fully develop. Additionally, many
biological processes or diseases are
impacted or driven by more than one
gene, so removing a single one might
not replicate all disease symptoms.
Lastly, there are important biological
and genetic differences between mice
and humans, so observations made in
mice may not always translate to humans.
Regardless, from the time they were
first introduced, knockout mice have
become an indispensable part of many
biological laboratories around the
world, contributing to nearly every
scientific medical advance. Now,
knockout technology is used in many
different types of model organisms, for
instance, flies, worms and fish,
further revolutionizing scientific
research.